man we know the truth gang i'm not like
man
this [ __ ] you know i'm saying
kevin all that with otm and [ __ ] lonely
to roll along here the great man trophy
the trophies under the spirit
let me hear that
[Music]
[ __ ] my neck hurt i'm nothing like
these new raptors things wanna see no
need no brown we the new jacket i'll
hand these old [ __ ] up like a new
jacket
who tripping nobody don't be a casualty
diamonds pop locking on my neck who they
battling i know your tyson's the younger
you're the tattletail the truth with
this [ __ ] like literally my style
getting back you thought you was [ __ ]
with me literally the wildest [ __ ] ever
what's that on your neck five pounds or
better you run up on the plug i
guarantee i'm gonna stretch a roughly
with chili
[Music]
[ __ ] to flow flyers have a [ __ ]
doing parkour when i shoot where i'm
ling ling pop pop and do you understand
me suck a christian up with holy water
pass the ralphie fry [ __ ] up and take
that ticket from him
how you get stripped with your strap
he's instantly moving too fast why you
taking off your panties everybody know
about this thing just going ask slapping
on her eyes chains hanging with the mac
on me tear it off you don't got the
green baby cash at
me i could get any [ __ ] i want cause my
necklace can pee with his flow flying
man i don't got no answer wanna know the
price of this chain [ __ ] ass romney he
is so rude the [ __ ] like it cause i'm
so cocky
broke [ __ ] shane diamonds stepped in
with a fan why you so violent get my
tips from the ruler stupid [ __ ] i
alrighty all my [ __ ] got q switch they
all licensed a cliffhanger it was tragic
left from rock climbing we know the
truth
say my name louder i know you blew them
all this booster where this man trousers
everything about my life i am not
rapping mum walking on the loafie this a
big pile uh
[ __ ] otm a big problem crunch time duffy
coming clutch like i'm black mamba we
keep scoring on these [ __ ] so they mad
at us don't reply to broke [ __ ] up a
bag on them the winning recipe that
stinks got the sauce told the [ __ ] they
don't wonder unless she bad and she a
boss [ __ ] is fascinated by the way i
walk just know it costs man down bro
that child doctor kid just whacked her
out chalk the block now we willy nelson
on the road again i hope you all know we
bringing stripes so we ain't coming in
try it then i told the bad [ __ ] to
bring both her friends minnie draco i
bet this gonna make it make sense too
icy i don't see nobody [ __ ] with us
how these [ __ ] do it don't you get it
[ __ ] we run the city anytime you see me
bet you i got pippi with me competition
i don't think these [ __ ] feel me [ __ ]
i ain't mean to hit her she had a fatty
owner back then i had to do but now i
pack a punched it chopsticks for king
kong it's a chunky monkey i don't know
about melinda we don't answer questions
what do you say [ __ ] [ __ ] them we
[ __ ] them over
[Music]
hey i know you just watched a crazy
freestyle uh presented by our good folks
at lrg we drop them once a week and
shout out to lrg man
i promise you
lrg's [ __ ] back they got some of the
flyers gear period we just did a crazy
collaboration with the suns before they
got blown out in game seven by the
mavericks so much cool stuff going on
get you some gear go to the website
below
l-r-g.com and use the promo code bootleg
and save 30 off your entire cart that's
right 30 off use that promo code bootleg
and check back in next week for another
freestyle